[Musique]
serge tu m'entends tu es en régie ouais
parce que là je suis sur scène je n'ai
pas beaucoup de temps c'est quoi le
texte déjà sérieux je rêve d'une banque
à 90 d'accord c'est pas pour cet
événement ok bon ouais pas de problème
non employés je me rappelle maintenant
ok ouais je suis très content d'être là
parmi vous aujourd'hui
vraiment et quand je quand j'ai appris
que j'allais participer à une conférence
ted
je me suis dit ryad il faut que tu
mettre le paquet il faut que tu fasses
quelque chose d'exceptionnel
un truc qui n'est qu'ils n'ont jamais
vus et qui les phrases souvenir de vous
de toi en l'occurrence je me vouvoie de
temps en temps ça m'arrive du coup j'ai
décidé de commencer par vous raconter
une histoire
alors je sais c'est pas très original
cependant il s'agit de mon histoire et
c'est en cela que c'est exceptionnel
1 j'ai une annonce à vous faire j'ai
arrêté de fumer
[Applaudissements]
ça fait chaud au coeur franchement quand
c'est spontané comme ça effectivement
1 j'ai commencé à l'âge de 40 ans je
sais c'est pas très malin
j'en ai 45 je sais je les fais pas
cinq ans c'est à la fois rien est énorme
quand on y pense et surtout quand on
connaît les dégâts que peut causer
d'être là bas 1
pourtant les pouvoirs publics ne cessent
de nous sensibiliser sur les dangers de
la cigarette
1 vous avez vu la dernière campagne
à propos du paquet neutre et les photos
qui y sont associés petit florilège
vous avez tout d'abord les soft quoique
cracher de la fumée au visage d'un bébé
on a connu un peu plus soft
ensuite vous avez les glauque
là on aborde le thème de la mort no
coment et enfin vous avez les trash
qui sont franchement limite et bien
aucune de ces photos ne m'a incité à
arrêter
non c'est une photo qui circulait sur
les réseaux sociaux humoristique qui a
été le déclic
étonnant quand on y pense parce que vous
comme moi aurions pu faire ce calcul
relativement simple oui mais là il était
affiché sous mes yeux avec une image qui
était loin d'être anodine alors pourquoi
ça marche et je vais vous expliquer en
1972 des psychologues de l'université de
stanford ont mené l'expérience suivante
un chamallow était offert à chaque
enfant puis l'expérimentateur sortait de
la pièce et s'absenter pendant un quart
d'heure avant de sortir de consigne
était donnée aux enfants ils pouvaient
soit consommé le chamallow de suite et
l'expérience prenait fin pour eux ou
bien attendre que l'expérimentateur
reviennent et recevoir un deuxième
schéma l'on récompense deviner ce que
firent la grande majorité des enfants
effectivement ils préférèrent la
récompense immédiate à celle différé en
fait notre cerveau est ainsi programmée
sous certaines perspectives dans
certaines conditions
il préfère effectivement la perspective
justement d'une récompense immédiate à
une récompense plus avantageuses mais
différée et phénomène s'appelle
l'actualisation hyperbolique
mais ce n'est pas réservé qu'aux enfants
les adultes comme vous et moi
ils sont aussi sensibles tenez si je
vous demande par exemple de choisir
entre gagner 5 euros aujourd'hui
ou bien wiese rôdant dans un mois la
grande majorité d'entre vous choisiront
la première option
et lorsque l'on scanne le cerveau des
personnes à qui l'on pose cette question
on voit qu'on allume des structures dans
le cerveau qui interviennent dans le
réseau de la récompense d'où le choix
effectivement du gain immédiat même si
d'un point de vue strictement logique
ce choix n'est pas optimale si
maintenant je vous propose de choisir
entre gagner 5 euros aujourd'hui et 0
euros dans un mois ou bien 0 euros
aujourd'hui et vise euros dans un mois
alors vous serez beaucoup plus enclins à
choisir la deuxième offre pourtant dans
l'absolu les perspectives je dirais de
gains sont terrés sont identiques
et si j'avais pu scanner votre cerveau
en vous proposant ce deal en fait
j'aurais vu s'allumer un autre réseau de
structures qui intervient dans le
contrôle je dirais de nos réponses
impulsive et puis aussi le contrôle de
nos choix réfléchi en fait qu'est ce que
j'ai fait en vous proposant la deuxième
proposition de 7 cette manière eh bien
je faisais l'objet
c'est à dire que j'ai orienté votre
décision vers un choix rationnel un peu
l'image du paquet de cigarettes qui m'a
incité à arrêter de fumer
alors qu'est ce qu'un nuage c'est un
terme anglais qui signifie coup de pouce
dans les faits ce sont des incitations à
caractère non obligatoire qui vise à
promouvoir les comportements vertueux
pour cela ils vont s'appuyer sur la
prédictibilité de nos erreurs de
jugement que l'on appelle des biais
cognitif
ainsi à l'image du judoka qui utilise la
force de son adversaire pour l'utiliser
à bon escient les neiges vont s'appuyer
sur la force de nos biais cognitifs pour
orienter passivement nos comportements
vers des options beaucoup plus raisonnée
et réfléchi je vous donnais trois
exemples de nods et vous préciser sur
quel biais cognitifs il s'appuie
le premier exemple repose sur notre
nature spontanément joueuse mais dom
préparez vous à entrer dans les secrets
les plus intimes de la gente masculine
bienvenue aux toilettes hommes de
l'aéroport international d'amsterdam
figurez vous que cette petite mouche
placés stratégiquement dans le fond de
l'urinoir a permis de réduire de 80% les
frais liés au nettoyage des toilettes
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
faut-il vous faire un dessin bref on
s'amuse comme on peut même aux toilettes
malheureusement aucun scan n'a pu être
réalisé pour voir quelle zone du cerveau
étaient activées
durant ce moment intime 1
pour le dire simplement ce dispositif
relativement simple fait que la mouche
permet à nous les hommes de mieux viser
le donne le deuxième exemple s'appuie
sur un phénomène que l'on appelle la
pression sociale afin de permettre aux
ménages de contrôler ou de réduire leur
consommation d'électricité
ce fournisseur d'énergie leur a fait
suivre une facture sur laquelle figurait
en plus de la consommation personnelle
ici en bleu la consommation de
l'ensemble du voisinage ainsi que la
consommation de des voisins les plus éco
responsable ici en verre et asselin été
rajouté un émoticônes qui souriait ou
bouder selon la consommation du ménage
en question résultats par simple effet
de comparaison sociale les ménages /
consommateurs ont sensiblement baissé
leur consommation dès le mois suivant et
les sous consommateurs ont maintenu leur
consommation tout aussi basse le dernier
exemple s'appuie sur un biais qui
s'appelle le biais de réciprocité qui
fait que nous nous sentons redevable de
quelqu'un lorsque celui ci nous rendre
un service
l'aide humanitaire souffre de dépenses
inutiles liés à ce que l'on appelle la
sueur inclusion c'est à dire en fait de
l'aide qui est offerte à des personnes
qui ne nécessite pas vraiment et le tri
est difficile parce que si l'on met en
place des conditions un peu trop
restrictives on risque alors d'exclure
des personnes pour qui l'aide est vite à
une orange a eu l'idée suivante plutôt
que de délivrer directement des
pastilles de chlore afin de désinfecter
l'eau de consommation
elle donnait aux populations des bons
qu'ils pouvaient échanger gratuitement
dans un centre qui se trouvait à
quelques kilomètres de leur village
contre ses bastides
l'or résultat la sueur inclusion a
quasiment disparu sans pour autant
entraîner de l'asu inclusion en fait les
personnes se mirent tâche allait
chercher par dont les capsules
uniquement lorsqu'elle en avait vraiment
besoin
alors les résultats que je vous ai
montré au travers de ces trois exemples
font très probablement sens pour vous
cependant pour qu'un comportement soit
pérenne et durable dans le temps les
neurosciences nous ont appris que le bon
sens ne suffisait pas il faut que les
émotions prennent leur juste place et le
spot de la campagne que vous aller
visualiser va concrétiser un peu cela
[Musique]
en continu
pourtant de tous
[Musique]
merci pour eux merci pour eux c'est
puissant n'est ce pas qu'est ce qui
s'est passé en fait de pendant cette
vidéo on a vu comment la recherche d'une
récompense personnelle et immédiate un
t-shirt à 2 euros s'est transformé en un
acte désintéressé aux bénéfices lointain
le don à une personne totalement inconnu
et cela n'est possible non pas en
faisant appel à des émotions simples
comme la colère le dégoût la joie mais
en suscitant chez les gens des émotions
réfléchi et complexe ici en l'occurrence
l'empathie alors je terminais on voudrez
sans je dirais peut-être l'avenir des
matchs de demain quel avenir pour les
matchs de demain nos connaissances en
neurosciences vont nous permettre de
design et des matches plus intelligent
notons plus conforme à l'ergonomie du
fonctionnement cérébral et la
technologie aura pleinement son rôle à
jouer afin de relancer nage vraiment
ingénieux mais aussi de permettre leur
diffusion au niveau mondial d'ailleurs
demain commence déjà aujourd'hui cette
application littérature vous permet ou
que vous soyez dans le monde de prendre
des photos de déchets ou de détritus que
vous voyez dans l'eau que vous trouvez
dans la rue dans la nature et de les
poster l'astuce c'est que chaque photo
est géotaguer avec une date vous
constituer ainsi un catalogue qui crée
un témoignage digital et ces témoignages
digitaux vont permettre de créer des
class actions virtuelles qui font que
les marques se doit inciter à investir
davantage dans le ramassage et la
collecte et le tri des déchets en
question et après demain
pourquoi pas des robots nageurs et bien
on y travaille et pas seulement pour les
personnes âgées ou bien celles atteintes
de handicap chez qui cela se développe
déjà imaginé des robots qui puisse vous
aider à rester en bonne santé à faire
les choix alimentaires sains en
pratiquant les activités physiques
nécessaires
imaginez des robots qui puisse aider
parents et enseignants dans l'éducation
de vos enfants afin de les rendre
d'autant plus qu' réactif l'est d'autant
plus responsable dans un monde dont la
complexité ne cesse de croître
imaginez enfin des robots qui puisse
vous aider à épargner davantage et ce
sans vous priver mais en dépensant mieux
les possibilités sont multiples et on ne
parlerait plus d'intelligence
artificielle mais d'intelligence et en
deux hommes et machines à vent sont
mutuellement
mais ça c'est une autre histoire
d'ici là not me it's you can merci
[Applaudissements]